y diego armando maradona amado y odiado
una figura que trascendió al fútbol
tanto que debe ser de los pocos humanos
con su propia religión la iglesia
maradoniana más allá de sus tantos
maradona fue considerado dios una figura
tan grande que terminó consumida por su
propia sombra tuvo polémicas dentro del
campo como la mano de dios en los
cuartos de final del mundial de méxico
de 1986 contra inglaterra un gol con la
mano que él mismo denominó como la
venganza por las islas malvinas también
en el terreno de juego en su época en el
barcelona dio la vuelta al mundo su
agresión a dos futbolistas del athletic
club de bilbao un suceso que le costó un
castigo de tres meses de sanción pero
más allá del campo en barcelona también
empezó su etapa más oscura allí comenzó
a consumir drogas las cuales marcaron su
carrera él mismo dijo que esta adicción
dio ventajas al resto de futbolistas en
1991 el mundo del fútbol quedó
conmocionado por su positivo por cocaína
un dopaje que se repetiría en 1994 antes
del mundial en esta ocasión por efedrina
en ese momento cansado del acoso de
parte de la prensa el jugador sacó un
rifle del aire
y disparo a los periodistas la adicción
le llevó al borde de la muerte en 2000 y
2004 pero el personaje va más allá de
sus adicciones en 2014 su pareja en ese
momento rocío oliva difundió un vídeo en
el que se veía a diego armando en estado
de ebriedad golpeando las polémicas
donde tampoco faltó a la política
maradona nunca olvidó sus orígenes
siempre recordó el hambre que pasaba a
su madre para alimentarles unas
vivencias que le llevaron a un gran
compromiso político forjando amistad con
personajes como fidel castro o hugo
chávez además de lucir siempre el
tatuaje del che guevara 60 intensos años
de maradona carismáticos muchas veces
polémicos muchas otras y como él siempre
dijo no es fácil ser maradona